we'll stay in texas now where a judge
has temporarily blocked the state from
investigating parents who obtain gender
transitioning medical care for their
children the decision follows governor
greg abbott's directive for child
protective services to investigate
parents who approved the treatments
likening it to child abuse on friday
apple google metta and johnson johnson
publicly objected to the measure and
thousands of families find themselves
under attack omar villafranca has more
this 14 year old is the transgender son
of amber and adam brigel they don't want
us to use his first name because last
week child protective services showed up
at their house to find out if his
parents were providing care related to
their son's transition i was
in the fetal position on the floor
gripping the floor because the room
wouldn't stop spinning the stakes have
never been this high or real
for us last month republican texas
attorney general ken paxton issued a
legal opinion that said gender affirming
procedures and treatments when performed
on children can legally constitute child
abuse texas children's hospital the
country's largest pediatric facility
paused all gender affirming therapy for
children
republican state senator charles perry
agrees with the directive's intent i'm
faced with the welfare of a child that
in
and i think the data supports it that is
not mature to have these decisions being
made for them to understand
in 2016 the briggles invited paxton and
his wife to their house for dinner to
talk about transgender issues paxton
even took a picture with their son they
know we're not child abusers they know
we're not child abusers he sat at my
table and broke bread with my family
and then says that families like mine
should not exist it's a political stunt
this directive is being challenged in
court but for now the briggles and other
parents of nearly 14 000 transgender
texas teenagers feel their future is up
in the air for cbs saturday morning omar
villafranca dallas